[Musique]
quel sens pour l'homme de la rue
les signes de l'indépendance des signes
de ce maroc nouveau
[Musique]
il ya les plaques qui porte le nom du
souverain dans les avenues principales
les drapeaux qui flottent seul sur les
édifices publics et les inscriptions en
arabe sur les façades des ministères il
ya aussi ces hommes de l'armée de
libération le qui-vive pacifiquement au
milieu d'une population
il semble avoir oublié le bruit des
mitraillettes et l'éclatement des
grenats ils sont en cours
d'incorporation tout simplement dans
l'armée royale est dans une journée de
détection
[Musique]
ces petites quatre chevaux d'orge
intrigue tout le monde
elle sillonne depuis quelques jours les
rues de rabat ainsi que d'autres comme
celle ci dans les autres villes du maroc
de façon à surveiller et à donner
éventuellement une alerte ou à le
secourir des cas extrêmes en difficulté
par cette jupe radio
[Musique]
voici la lettre donnée au seuil m
l'équivalent de nos crs français mais
aussi pour la première fois une section
marocaine de ces iem
ces hommes aguerris
toutes les techniques modernes duclos
scandent maths ne s'apprête pas à
arrêter ces deux femmes voilées elles ne
commettent pas à l'afro autant dans ce
d'émancipation de la femme en gardant
leurs voiles car on voit encore beaucoup
tam voilée dans les rues et
l'émancipation en est encore à un stade
très discret l'émancipation de la femme
et surtout dirigées par des groupements
patriotiques et aussi par une équipe pas
décelé de brain trust composé de hautes
personnalités dans lesquels mes films en
effet ahmed balafrej unis d'affaires
étrangers est à fellini à féministe
endiablé et fatima hassar qui est sorti
d'une milice des françaises et la
demoiselle dans la presse de publier les
progrès sont les véritables su projet
ces danseuses du bled el quoique dévoilé
ne sont pas des suffrages à présent
toujours été dévoilée ce sont les femmes
des oasis du sud non loin de déversant
saharien du grand atlas
sur les souks autrement dit marcher de
madère du bled
la vie est toujours la même les hommes
en garde et le vêtement traditionnel et
se livrent leurs activités habituelles
[Musique]
ok l'air maussade
un gentil sourire qui comparent ans
je
[Musique]
nous avons quitté le blaze nous
assistons maintenant à l'examen
d'aptitude physique de la première
promotion marocaine des moniteurs
d'éducation de base
[Musique]
berne l'armée royale
la jeune armée marocaine incorpore
aujourd'hui un détachement de membres de
l'armée de libération
on les reconnaît généralement à leur
passe montagne surmonté d'une cerise un
petit peu lent signe distinctif ils vont
toucher leurs uniformes et bientôt il
n'y aura plus en train de chanter qu'un
seul maroc sous le même univers
[Musique]
la jeune armée marocaine a aussi ses
blindés et pour la première fois des
équipages entièrement marocains ont été
formés par les moniteurs français vont
vous faire une belle démonstration
[Musique]
tous les efforts du jeune maroc pour
devenir un pays moderne que nous ne
trouvons pas seulement que dans l'armée
l'administration
il ya aussi le maroc
au travail l'inde maroc des travailleurs
pour lutter contre le chômage le
gouvernement a institué un peu partout
des chantiers
on ne répond pas du goudron mon pain
aussi débarque dans le vieux-port de
mogador
et dans l'ultra-moderne par le casa
blanca la fourmilière
[Musique]
mais le vendredi tout ce travail toute
cette volonté et ardeur au travail
s'arrête pour le jour de repos est de ma
belle et tous ceux qui peuvent venir
arabe a assisté à labrihe et 18 ans le
nid mende par milliers
le souverain sa majesté ce qui m'avait
sabres soit les acclamations de son
peuple à l'occasion de cette prière
bilan la russie
il est à cheval de façon à ce qu'on
puisse au mieux le voir il contemplait
qu'il rentre dans son palais une fois la
prière terminée
[Musique]
nous nous inquiétons de sa part où sont
les français dans le maroc indépendant
mais voici quelques images qui nous les
montre en pleine action à l'abbaye
bénédictine de thionville in voici le
cours international organisé par les
moines bénédictins et qui a réuni
français et marocains dans une
magnifique réussite de contact
des moniteurs forme de futurs spécialisé
transmission les policiers veillent à la
sécurité
les motards comme dans toutes les
capitales d'europe et le sont les
motards français qu encore le souverain
et les jeunes moniteurs de qu'ils soient
de la jeunesse et des sports ou de
l'armée royale le sont là pour former
aussi les futures car au maroc
[Musique]